if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
for the fans of the harry potter
franchise there's so many nuggets in
there
it's incredible everybody around you
is as excited as you are you know that
nostalgia that everyone has gets in my
dna as it is for a lot of people there
are so many memories there's a feeling
of coming home so grindelwald is at
large and dumbledore has recruited this
group of wizards to go and hunt him down
they're going to hogwarts to meet with
dumbledore and dumbledore lets them into
his plan the fact that everything didn't
go precisely to plan was precisely the
plan but i think what excites me the
most is the opportunity to return to a
place that we grew to love in harry
potter films hogwarts has been in
people's lives for so long i
grew up reading the books so to be a
part of beasts it's literally like a
fantasy everyone knows harry potter i
got to be at hogwarts for this movie for
me that was really special jacob look
who i found hey
it's my wizard friends we're
they
like
this
exciting and familiar locations within
hogwarts we see quidditch going on
little quidditch players we see
significant characters in this wonderful
world it takes you out of your own world
it was so
surreal to walk onto these sets
what is this place
the room we require
being able to shoot in the great hall is
very special there were loads of kids
there he felt very harry pottery
the slytherin boys over there they gave
me these the delicious who wants one i
never cared for cockroach clusters much
myself
i mean the first time i walked into the
hog's head i was like this is one of the
craziest jobs ever they've created this
battered beautiful old pub i really
wanted to just grab a drink and sit down
by the fire
it was so authentic
these films have a place in people's
lives it takes you right back to the
potters
that's just the coolest thing correct
three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you